okay it's time to check out the
sidelines and amongst them the first
move I want to consider is
E6 a pretty bad choice because generally
caroan player wants that Bishop outside
the pawn chain and here I think they are
playing right into the White's hand as
the structure we are going to witness
that is D4 C5 and C3 clearly resemble
the French Advance where unfortunately
black Bishop is completely a bad
piece so I'm sure it is white who is
more prepared in this position rather
than
black last but not least what to do
against the move
C5 which is although not been played
very often from this position I think
it's Black's best
bat and against this what else we are
are going to rect our Pawn chain with
C3 Knight to C6 and
D4 okay black has few options and
amongst them if he continue with Bishop
to G4 then this directly transpose into
our first line with d capture C5 and
after E6 do you remember Bishop to E3
and have shown earlier why this line is
so good for the white
the second move Bishop to F5 is also
frequently played from here but I think
this is a slightly inaccurate Choice as
now white can take on
C5 whereupon his idea is after
E6 he wants to play B4 and hold on to
his
material a sample line can run like this
A5 Bishop to
B5 a takes B4 and pawn takes B4 where
the end result is very clear white is a
healthy Pawn up with a quinide majority
and with some careful play this is
definitely a position which white will
certainly
enjoy finally black can play the
accurate Choice here namely C captures
D4 and after c captures D4 now he can
play Bishop to G4 which I personally
think is the best response by the
black however still black has to
negotiate some nasty tricks by the
white the general peace layout goes like
this bishop to E3
E6 Bishop to
D3 black give this check and after
Knight to C3 he complete his speace
development with Knight to E7
but after Castle on the king
side exactly here we sets up yet another
tricky platform as the most frequent
Choice by the black such as Castle on
the king side and Knight to F5 turn out
to be a mistake by the
black let's check how the first option
Castle is a pretty bad choice and
everybody who have seen my Greek gift
sacrifices they can instantly spot in
this
position Bishop takes
that if black king doesn't take it then
white can drop his Bishop back with a
clear Pawn Advantage so more or less
black has to take it whereupon we play
Knight to G5 and after King to G8 and
queen captures
G4 on top of extra material white has
some scary attack coming up with Queen
movement on H5 and
altoe this position is fun to play as a
white against the second popular choice
Knight to F5 I recommend white should
start with H3 nabbing the bishop pair
and setting up yet another tricky
platform so if you carefully look at
this position the D4 Pawn is hanging and
as happened in the majority of the cases
black has indeed taken up this Pawn but
the matter of fact is after Queen to G4
suddenly white get a completely winning
position well the engine suggest that
black should play G5 but in that case
black king remain in the center and
practically you don't expect such a
continuation from the black side so by
far the most popular choice is Knight to
F5 whereupon the task is very simple you
take on
F5 black has to
recapture now you take on
G7 and after Rook to f8 I think this
position completely stinks from the
black
perspective he has some horrible Pawn
structure with the King stuck in the
center and let me show you some further
moves which shows how pathetic black
position is Bishop to G5 attacking the
Queen Bishop to E7 you take the bishop
black is forced to capture back with the
Knight whereupon the end result Knight
to B5 and white has a l laugh as Knight
to D6 is coming up where it is just
matter of time where black has to press
the resign
button that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn my tricky raputa against the
carakan the line I have shown here are
very rarely played yet well analyzed by
chess engine and most important feature
is it contain lot of tricks against
caran something which we desperately
need in the tournament
practice well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I will see you in my
next episode very
soon bye and take
care